if you were to start all over again yep
from scratch
yes yes I'd go work for somebody that I
Meyer for free for four years I would
try to get the Jeff besos in work for
him for free for free for four years I
would literally sleep on the couch of an
acquaintance and eat fast food for 99
cents a day for four years to work for
Jeff Bezos [ __ ] I might be willing to do
that right now I believe that in 20
years it will be commonplace for
individuals to pay the best business
leaders to work for them not the other
way around it's a very weird thing
that's starting to manifest in my head
because it's just black and white to me
that that's where the value is get as
close to the Sun of the thing that you
want to be and you will win if you're
capable and you hear that you know now
that I've gotten curious about it you
you know you start watching these
documentaries or you dig into the
successful people the amount of people
that started off as grabbing coffee for
the guy or the gal they want it to be
and then became it and I would do that
my man I would you know or or I you know
the thing is back it's back to guessing
it's funny the Bezos thing or somebody
else the other thing I would do is try
to get very close to the voice space but
it's funny how I don't want to go there
because I wouldn't know which founder
was the good one to build on top of the
voice space so I went to the platform or
something that I established but I I
genuinely believe that when you're young
time is your biggest leverage and that
what you should do is build leverage
with the leaders of the world that you
want to if you want to be a hip hop
mogul go work for Puff Daddy for free
for three years right we're so we're so
pressured by our parents to start making
money at 22 23 I think everybody should
legitimately have a totally different
strategy from 22 to 34 everybody here
over 45 you know how young 30 is and I
think everybody here who's 4550 if I
said hey what about spending 22 to 30
and only working for the person that you
admired the most for free I think a lot
more people would have taken that up on
than what they actually did which is do
[ __ ] to pay for their rent and like
just don't [ __ ] like very intriguing to
me that that's where the leverage is
gonna go if you want to be a great
creative whoever the 10 best creative
directors in the world now have the
leverage you know like so that's what I
would do thank you guys
[Applause]
patience it is the imperative foundation
of anything that is long-term successful
what because when you are an impatient
person or organization you tend to make
short-term decisions which have been
proven historically as something that
creates a vulnerable usually to
long-term growth
[Music]
Oh
it's a vlog just going to the airport
now in Oslo on our way to Copenhagen
then to Moscow back in the USSR as they
say anyway good talk this morning and
breakfast just in a huge meeting with
Eric in the back of the cab so many
people wasting time
I just basically had a London office
meeting on the way here that's how you
hack it sometimes having somebody travel
the expensive is worth it because the
ROI of the meeting in serendipity things
like a cab ride make it ry+ continue to
hack your time for your dollars
[Music]
I tweeted the other day zero percent of
zero zero
a lot of people laughed and made jokes
but it's funny somebody was negotiating
against me in some business world where
they were gonna take a zero Commission
and on this thing I don't wanna be too
specific anyway which I replied to the
person that they were pitching it to I'm
like cool when they bring you nothing
it's not gonna matter
zero percent of zero is zero for that
company that person so
you can pass on my 20% but when I bring
400,000 you'd get 320 when that person
brings you zero you're gonna get zero
always wonder why somebody's willing to
work on zero Commission it's either
because they're unbelievable and they're
making money in some other spot in that
overall relationship or just cuz they
can't deliver in that craft this
situation was the second one that
empties not gonna bring you anything
it won't love you know cuz I love them
first
whom I waited three hours I have to go
to another city and only just you gotta
quit up here
Thanks everything oh you're welcome man
I think people should sleep six seven
eight hours depending on your body I'm a
huge advocate and what the [ __ ] are you
doing the other 18 hours right and so
when I hear your question answers of
course you should you know you should
yeah you know you should test that
everybody here should spend meaningful
amounts of time testing everything
everything you know that's what you're
supposed to be doing cuz you don't know
the answer for your specific nuance
if LinkedIn or a podcast or influencer
marketing or you know you don't know if
that's gonna be the turning point and
what you're doing is you're doing too
many things people are keeping their
time precious when it's their biggest
asset people are not reinvesting money
back into their business because they
want to buy dumb [ __ ]
people are not flying things because if
they fail they worry about what other
people think about that failure and so
they're we're all you know the answer is
yes to everything
I'm literally [ __ ] I'm like yes and I
can leave and go [ __ ] and fly to LA
right now because the next three hours
is yes this it's yes
so of course you should like what are
you doing for 18 hours a day find an
hour and do it for an hour every day to
get to the answer and then also
understand that the first 10 times you
do it it might not be right because it's
like you know I was talking about the
ROI people like what's the ROI of
influencers or vrs or the ROI of those
ten hours reaching out to influencers
the ROI of a basketball is very
different to people to me it's nothing
to LeBron James it's a billion dollars
so all this stuff works its are you good
at is a whole nother question so it's
not just the ROI of trying it then you
got to get good at it nothing you're
good at right now you were so great out
the first time you tried it so of course
man like everything that's happening
you need to figure out how it works for
your business b2b b2c personal brand the
question is what are you doing with your
time you know and so that's why I I
could get back who want to be an
entrepreneur and watch four hours of
Netflix a weekend or and by the way
people need escapism you need to check
out you need to rest you have to be in a
mental place but the scrutiny that we
have to put on our time as young
entrepreneurs you know it's just time or
Monday talent is the variable that sits
in front but the assets that you're
sitting with in the beginning of time
and then you mass money and then you can
use the money to save time and it's
going back and everybody wants these big
dreams and they're not willing to work
at the level they need to when that's
the advantage they have so [ __ ] yes you
should yeah I'm really looking forward
to the flight to Moscow and more
importantly Moscow to LA that's crazy
we're in the airport for eight hours oh
I assume we have lounge and we're just
gonna fall asleep in the corner on the
chair that looks like this so we're
gonna do I mean it's gonna honestly I'm
very excited I've never been to the USSR
since I've left in 1970 so it's actually
a fun day but I can't leave need a visa
and I didn't know I was I didn't even
know until two days ago we were
connecting through Moscow
just to run to Red Square and do a
meet-up it would have been awesome
it's inspired me to want to go back I I
don't know what we're in there but yeah
I'm tired
felt pretty good about that I'm really
excited to see everybody here in
Copenhagen credible credible city really
good day
got some good content was a lot oh yes
we've got have to go to the airport we
got to go we have four hour flight to
Moscow eight hour layover in Moscow
links meaning I'm a much bigger brand
than vaynermedia yet I service no
clients okay and it was because I knew
that that was the trap hole and no again
remember when I said I [ __ ] up with
Google yeah when you do it you know you
did the right thing but now the right
thing in this mature State when you
recognize it is the power of no because
if we're here three years later you're
like Gary I remember like yeah the guy
with two earrings like now there's no
excuse now that you know now it's just
down to execution yeah I mean there's a
couple ways to go that it you like I'm
sorry you can't have me I've built it up
I've built my team or you can go a
different route okay Rick Sarah you know
Hans Mons like you want me well what we
told you 5,000 a month is actually
30,000 a month if you want me there's a
lot of moves that you can have there's
always gonna be an excuse you're a
hundred percent in charge you know what
the issue is either address it or don't
there's one of two ways you do what I
you know I've scaled that and I've done
it by hiring around two things one
everything I don't want to do to
everything that I know I'm not as good
at than the other things that I spend my
time on which means I spent 30 percent
of my time on HR
like you look at my calendar I'm just
meeting with my employees talking about
somebody else that they're mad at but
that's what I do so special that allows
me to build what I build right so um
it's about leaving money on the table in
the short term my friend you're trying
to maximize the profit instead of
reinvesting it into people and having
people do be versus you're a it's about
building a business in five years
instead of one year
similar to him and nobody wants to give
up the short term he doesn't he says yes
for another fifty thousand and twenty
five thousand or two thousand a month or
whatever it is instead of saying no and
then you know because it's exciting to
take people get caught up in top-line
revenue or profit and it's always about
tweaking those two things also ego hurts
these stories a lot you like the feeling
of being the best of the best I listen
to every word you know
[Music]